this is a production of cornell
university
uh thanks for coming can you hear me can
the people in the back hear me okay
great
um
so as eric mentioned today i'll be
talking about my dissertation research
and focused on this topic of the
mysteries of the marsh looking at soil
borne plant pathogens and marsh wetlands
and their impact on invasive and native
plant species
and
through my dissertation research i've
been really trying to answer the
question of whether soil pathogens are
contributing to the success of invasive
plants and marsh wetlands
and a lot of the work that i've done is
displaying the groundwork to answer this
question so today's seminar i'm going to
be focusing on presenting to you
a few experiments that are answering
questions i think really enable us to
start to answer that question and that
is do invasive plants change soil in a
way that decreases seedling survival and
if so how
which omi seeds and fungi are present in
marshwell and soils and are these omi
seeds and fungi pathogens of marsh
plants and if so how virulent are they
so in this picture you can see two
fields right here where i work at the
north end of cayuga lake in the
mountains in the wetlands complex here
on the left you have something that
perhaps is a little more familiar to
those of us in this room and in this
department this is a wheat field and on
the right this is a marsh wetland so you
can see a lot of differences right off
the bat between these two areas but
i think the biggest difference and kind
of relatively the biggest difference
between agricultural areas
which are highly managed and less
managed more natural areas is diversity
so this diversity
is both the richness and evenness of
species so the richness being the number
of species that are there their evenness
being their abundance relative to each
other and it also happens on both a
genotypic and a spatial scale so if you
think of in this cornfield there's
probably just one genotype there one
species but also one genotype here
you're going to have a lot of different
species a lot of different phenotypes
within each species and the spatial
heterogeneity is much larger
so
one exception to the rule that natural
areas tend to be really highly diverse
are invasive plants and
by invasive plants i mean that these are
non-native plant species so they've
evolved somewhere else they've come to a
new place they're rapidly expanding
their range
and for the most part they have some
negative consequence either on humans
economically or on some ecosystem
services
like animal habitat or biodiversity of
plant species so in this picture you can
see two invasive plants dominating this
marsh wetland in the foreground here is
falaris or indonesia it's reed canary
grass in the background is phagmites
astralis phragmites are commonly and you
can see that they're both growing in
really dense
excluding the growth of other plant
species
so
if most natural areas are highly diverse
how are invasive plant species able to
do this able to grow so densely
and
a lot of uh ecological research has
looked into plant traits of these plants
so the fact that they're able to grow
really fast they can grow taller shade
out other plant species but increasingly
people are looking at the effect that
they're having on the soil
many invasive plants change soil
properties abiotic antibiotic in ways
that put them at an advantage in other
competitors at a disadvantage this is
called soil conditioning
and
i'm interested in how that's happening
with invasive plants and marsh wetlands
and is that different from what native
plants are doing
so just a little background on what's
happening in most kind of
native plants
natural systems you have density
dependent recruitment of seedlings which
contributes to the high diversity that
you see
so if you imagine the probability that a
seedling will survive
and the density of that particular plant
species in the soil
there's going to be
higher survival when that plant species
of low density and lowers survival when
that plant species is at high density
and the way that people found this out
was in the 1970s two ecologists jansen
mcconnell saw that in tropical forests
if there's a parent tree species uh it's
seedlings there's going to be a lot of
species near the parent and that's kind
of what i'm considering a high density
of that particular plant species
they're going to be a few seedlings that
are further away at low density of that
plant species
and that the seafoods near the parent
tree
die or do very poorly and those that are
further away at a low density have a
much higher probability of survival and
eventually fitness
so when they first
found this they thought that it was
probably mammals some kind of seed
predators
but increasingly people have found that
no it's plant pathogens in the soil that
are causing these effects
so related to that i wanted to know
what's going on with invasive plants if
they can avoid
those density dependent effects in the
soil so in this picture i really like
this because this is
phragmites
beautiful tall grass and right in the
background you have another beautiful
tall grass corn
and so a lot of the fields that i work
in are right next to agricultural fields
both of these are monocultures of very
dominant very tall grass species and so
those of you who work in agriculture
know it's really hard to get corn to
grow like this it doesn't naturally want
to not have weeds
if you didn't manage it if you didn't
rotate crops you have
big problems both with weeds and
diseases so how are invasive plant
species and this plant species in
particular how are they able to do this
with no inputs
and what people are finding is plants
have different pathogen interactions and
they're native and invaded ranges so if
you think back to those
density dependent soil effects and the
role of soil pathogens that they are
playing a role in the success of many
invasive plant species
so one example of this
why we think this is happening
is that if you grow the same plant
species for the most part in the same
soil year after year it's going to do
more poorly each time those of you in
agriculture know that this is the case
you have to rotate your crops
the same happens with native plants so
if you look at plant soil feedback
and over time it will be
lower and lower plant soil feedback
being the term for how much the soil
kind of feeds back to those plants
survival and success so native plants do
worse and basic plants don't and so
people have found that they
are neutral when grown in the same soil
or maybe even benefit from it and so
they're having some kind of different
interactions there for native plants
and what we think is happening one
hypothesis is called enemy release and
that is that when invasive plants come
they leave behind
pathogens from their
native range
and it takes time for them to accumulate
and acquire them
when they invade so if you imagine this
invasive plant in its native range it's
going to have a diverse group of
pathogens including some soil pathogens
i've illustrated here
when it leaves those behind in an
embedded range it can sometimes do
better because it's not experiencing
those density dependent magnetic
feedbacks so one classic example of this
was with prunus serotonin our black
cherry is invasive in europe and
it's able to grow in really dense stands
unlike here and the reason for that is
that it's encountering less virulent
soil pathogens particularly genus
pythium
that don't have the same density
dependent effects on seedlings so
seedlings are able to survive to
adulthood and that's why it can grown
system stands
so if that were happening in
a marsh wetlands you'd expect to see
invasive plant species less susceptible
to pathogens in the invaded range than
native plants and you'd expect that
native plants would accumulate more
virulent pathogens than invasives
another hypothesis for how invasive
plants are interacting with pathogens in
a way that puts them at an
advantage is that they're somehow
changing the pathogen population when
they invade uh in a way that puts native
plants at a disadvantage so this could
be them bringing in
pathogens with them
that would then spread into a native
community or it could be just something
about their arrival changes the pathogen
community in such a way that native
plants have higher disease and decay
survival so here we've got a plant
coming into a
mixed plant community an invasive plant
and it's bringing with it some pathogens
that would then spread into
the native plant community this
hypothesis is called spill back or spill
over and a few examples are with
invasive grasses in the western united
states
several are known to bring with them
viruses that will then spread into a
native plant population and increase the
disease that they're experiencing
another example that doesn't involve a
plant bringing in anything with it but
just changing the existing pathogen
community is with cheap grass also in
the western united states so cheap grass
is a prolific seed producer
after its arrival there's a lot more
seeds in the soil
the abundance of those seed pathogens
really increases and the native plants
have a hard time out competing
sheepgrass
so if that were happening you'd expect
to see a pathogen community changing
after an invasive plant colonizes
and you'd expect
maybe increased abundance or virulence
of pathogens after invasion
so here are a few different hypotheses
for how pathogens could be driving the
success of invasive plants
both because invasives escape pathogens
from their native range it takes time
for them to accumulate them in an
invaded range
and they might be able to change the
pathogen community when they invade so i
want to know how important these are for
invasive plant species
and particularly i want to know what's
going on in marsh wetlands so most of
the studies i just described take place
in forest and grassland systems but
marshes are really important for
understanding invasive success for a
number of reasons first off they're
highly invaded systems so if you think
about the
kind of most important invasive plants
in north america phragmites astralis
three canary grass purple blue stripe a
lot of those are in marshall islands
so understanding what's going on there i
think would be key
second march wetlands provide important
ecosystem services water quality
habitat
in this area a lot of the migratory
birds pass through where i work at the
north end of canada lake so
they need that habitat
there's also the issue of the kind of
different plants that are there these
invasive plants are preventing them from
growing
so the biodiversity
also there are lots of omi seats and
fungi in marsh soils when people have
looked so in europe they also have marsh
wetlands in fact some of our invasives
are needed there and so when people have
looked they found really abundant
communities so i want to know if that's
happening here
see bank establishment and seedling
establishment are really key for the
success of a lot of these plant species
so paired with the fact that there are a
lot of soil omi seeds and fungi
i think it's probable that there's some
interaction going on where pathogens
could be determining what the plant
communities look like
and then finally some of the pathogens
that are known to affect
the dieback or kind of death of a lot of
the root species in europe
are omyseeks
similar to what i think we find here so
i want to know if they're also playing
an important role in our marsh wetlands
so
before i begin i just want to introduce
you to a few of the plants i'll be
talking about first fragment is astralis
i've mentioned it before
it's non-native uh it's european and i
think it came here in the late 1800s and
since it's been replacing a lot of
native plant species you've probably
seen it on the roadsides it's kind of
lining a lot of the highways but it's
also important in wetlands and it forms
these large clonal patches like you can
see here extremely dense and quite tall
and can get up to 13 feet
and one of the interesting things about
pharmacies is that they're both native
and non-native genotypes here in north
america so that's a good species for us
to be looking at because it gives us a
closely related pair of native and
invasive
i'll also be talking about a couple
other bases palaris or indonesia green
canary grass
and lithuanic area purple blue stripe
you've also probably seen these around i
think this one is particularly beautiful
even though it isn't invasive
and i'll be mentioning a few native
plant species um
uh
epilobium glandulosum as a herbaceous
native plant palmer grasses candidances
grass species and the experiments i'll
be talking about i'll be using just a
wide variety of different native plant
species as kind of a proxy for what's
going on
in that community with less attention to
what particular hosts or plants are are
experiencing
so the first question i think
for determining if
plant pathogens and soil pathogens in
particular are playing a role in the
success of invasive plant species is
seeing does the invasive plant change
the soil in a way that decreases
seedling survival
so
i want to note phragmites australis that
invasive plant i mentioned initially
is changing the soil
and this could be abiotic or biotic some
invasive plants
exude allelopathic chemicals that are
toxic to other plant species
but i'm particularly interested in the
pathogens so i want to know
is it reducing seedling survival of
other plants and is this caused by soil
fungi and neuromyces
and so to get at this question
there are a couple different experiments
i'll mention right now
first i planted seedlings of eight
native plant species at four sites so
here you can see me
carefully of measuring some seedlings at
each side i cleared plots within and
outside of the stand of the front lines
so this you can see the dense sprague
bodies around me and the reason i
cleared those sites is that i wanted to
exclude factors like shading and
crowding that people typically think are
why fried vines is so successful and
just look in the field at the soil
so after a month i assess ceiling
survival
and here's a plot outside of the
fragments so you can see i've drawn a
square here just so you can see where
the plot is and the kind of much more
diverse vegetation outside of the
faculty is relative to inside of it and
you can see some little patches of green
here and what those are are the
seedlings that i transplanted this is
one of them the grass
and
what happened was that there was overall
lower survival in phragmite stands so
this is a portion of seedlings surviving
this is plant species transplanted so a
number of different plant species here
the yellow is inside and the green is
outside so overall there's a clear trend
that things did better outside of the
stands and inside there were some
site-specific effects so i think you
know these these soil changes take time
to accumulate so one of my sites was a
more recent invasion and it didn't have
those differences and because of that
it's only significant to a couple plant
species
but overall there's a clear trend that
pharyngeal seems to be doing something
to the soil that decreases the survival
of other plants but what is that so to
answer what exactly is happening in the
soil
i did a
secondary study with uh my collaborator
laura martin and some members of erin
glossy's lab um looking at
seasoned survival in a more controlled
container setting so i took soil or we
took soil from these fragments common
gardens
that had been conditioned grown with
phragmites and then planted 10 different
marsh wetland plant species in the soil
and half of these containers were
treated with broad spectrum
chlorothalofungicide
that should be somewhat effective
against both fungi and omi seeds to see
if you exclude those from the soil do
you still see fragments having a
negative effect on the survival of these
plant
and so as you can species there were
many containers
um and what we found is similar to uh in
the previous study for some species but
not all phragmites did have a negative
effect on ceiling survival so the brown
is potting mix the yellow is a fragments
conditioned soil and the green is that
soil with fungicide added
so the asterisks represent a significant
interaction or a contribution
of that factor to the proportion of
seedlings surviving so you can see that
for a few of these species
there was a significant decrease when
they were grown in the fragmented soil
but for pretty much all of them the
fungicide
increased survival and in many cases it
brought survival kind of back up to a
level that it would be in potting mix so
if you see right here and here
the fungicide is able to take away those
soil effects
so to answer that question does
phragmites
soil conditioning or the changes that it
makes to the soil affect seedling
survival and how
we did find that it decreases survival
of some plant species but not all
and that this was caused by soil and
fungi or soil or license and fungi for
some plant species
so we know that these fungi and almighty
seats are playing a role but we don't
know which species these are so my next
question was trying to identify
which omi seats and fungi are present
and my hypotheses were that they'd be
diverse and abundant um
both for fungi and omics just based on
what people have found in other systems
but that there would be different
pathogens or actually not pathogens
fungi or mystics seeds associated with
different plant species
the pathogen part will come later
so for the lmi seeds we sampled field
soil at four sites both phragmites
invaded and non-invaded
and we isolated on my seats using a leaf
bait method so here you can see uh
there's the soil at the bottom of this
tube it's filled with water and then
there are leaves at the top and that
selects foreign lysines because it
requires swirling zoospores to reach an
effect the leaves and then we used a
word selected media
and
after isolating
we extracted dna from the isolites and
sequenced
the its one and two region of the rrna
opera
and so
we've got about 500 isolates and as you
can see they're really dominated by
python species so some phytopythia and
some sacrolitemia but mostly pythium
and if you divide this up by which
pythium species were we seeing
uh pythium and platinum pithium
dissimile pithium heterothalcom and a
trantheridium and aquatile angus todd
and those are kind of the dominant
species but it's worth noting that a
really large percentage about 20
were species that only have less than 10
isolates so not only um
are we seeing
a lot so we're seeing a lot of different
species we're seeing some dominant
species but a lot of minor ones that
still might play a role
so
if you compare how frequently these
species were isolated from bragmani's
invaded and non-invaded soils you do see
some differences some species this is
the difference in isolation frequency
right here so a zero would mean that
there is no difference in how frequently
they are isolated from two soils
these are more common in non-infected
and these are more common in the
pragmatism dated soils
so you can see that some species pythium
irregularity and theophragmitis are more
common in the non-invaded soils while
others like pythium torilosum and
picking their anomalies were more common
in the invaded slaves
so to look at fungi we took a little
different approach
you can see my fantastic field assistant
here
planting containers containers in
january
and we buried seed baits at 10 sites
using seeds of nine different plant
species
and these seeds overwintered in the
field and in the spring we collected
them extracted the seeds from each
container
and then we isolated fungi
as you can kind of see this is a seed
from one of those containers and there's
some piping growing out so it took the
hypothesis for each
of isolate growing and
repeatedly transferred it so we can make
sure we have pure culture and then we
identified these isolates
sequencing them the same way and so far
i have a
larger culture collection of around a
thousand but so far we've sequenced
about
266 isolates and we're seeing a lot of
different fungal species so here's
alternaria boma epicoconum and fusarium
seem to be the dominant
genera
but there are a lot of others especially
in this group
general was left with one isolate
and so if we look at this
by plant species so remember we have
those nine different plant species that
we're isolating this fungi from you can
see different fungi are associated with
the seeds of different plant species
so each of these circles is a rough
roughly the number of isolates that we
have from each of those plant species so
this is calories and arundelia uh the
invasive that i mentioned with canary
grass so that has a pretty even mix of
different
genuses of fungi
but for phragmites uh it's very
dominated by foma also some alternaria
and carrick sprinkier which is a native
sedge
the dominant genus is alternaria that
we're finding associated with the seeds
and again i did surface to sterilize the
seeds before putting them into these
field sites but it's possible that some
of these
fungi are coming in with the seeds
rather than being acquired from the soil
but still some clear differences
uh which fungi and only seeds are
present in marshwell and soils
we did indeed find diverse and abundant
uh omisettes and fungi so for my seeds
the dominant genus was pithium for fungi
the dominant general were alternaria
foma and epicocom
and there did seem to be different
species associated with different plant
species so some fungi or mice it's more
common with
plant species
so
next
i want to know sure we know what's there
but what are they actually doing
so are these
pathogens of marsh plants and if so how
virulent are they
so my hypotheses going into this just
based on
the types of
genera that we were seeing pithium
in particular is that we find a lot of
generalist pathogens
but thinking back to some of those
hypotheses for why invasive plants are
so successful i expected that native
plants would be more susceptible
and that isolates from the native
species would be more virulent
so to test this we
set up bioassays
for both fungi and omi seats and here's
the structure of that
i added a crew isolates of each on an
auger plate and wait until the mycelia
had grown out
far enough and then added seeds
of different plant species to the cells
so this is a pretty artificial assay
it's definitely not what's going on in
the field but it at least gives us some
idea of whether or not
if given all of the opportunities
these isolates can be pathogenic
so by pathogenic i mean they decrease
seedling survival
when inoculated relative to a control
that's uninoculated and then for
virulence i'm defining that as the
degree of that decrease
so in this top frame you can see
a control
an inoculated plate growing with seeds
of fragmented strawless
in this one you can see a
non-pathogenic isolate so all of those
seedlings are doing great um here is a
low virulence isolate so one that does
decrease the survival of these seedlings
relative to a control but that they're
still pretty high seedling survival and
then in this bottom frame are some high
virulence isolates so few with any of
those seedlings are still surviving
so
we measured seedlings right about the
end of three weeks
and this is for the omi seeds i'll show
them first and then the fungi second so
think of this as a heat map with a
different pithium species here
in order of their relative abundance so
how frequently we isolated them from the
soil and here are the plant species that
we tested so these ones in green are
native these ones in yellow are mason
and what you can see is that some plant
species are highly susceptible so the
darker the red the kind of bigger impact
the more virulent those
pathogens are
and
those with a significant decrease from
the control so those i do pathogenic are
shaded in any shade of rent so those
that are white did not appear
significantly decrease ceiling survival
so the really dark red you can see here
epilobium glandulosa one of the native
plant species was the most susceptible
to these pathogens um and i think this
invasive lithium salicaria was kind of
also extremely susceptible um and you
can see when it inoculated it had very
low ceiling survival
the least was phalaris amnesia an
invasive plant species you can see none
of the isolates we looked at
significantly decreased ceiling survival
some of these
isolates were species were highly
virulent so pythium voludum pythium
phragmitis you can see that pretty much
across the board they decreased seedling
survival to around zero for the plants
that we tested
whereas others were
occasional pathogens or maybe very
weakly virulent pathogens such as
lithium citrinum right here
as well as lithium aqua tile
so another way to look at that same beta
would be spreading it out just looking
at two plant species this is a native
plant epilibium glandulosa the one that
i mentioned is really susceptible to
these pathogens and this isn't the
invasive crack bodies in yellow and
proportion seedling survival pythian
species tested
with asterisks for the significant
those that significantly decrease
ceiling survival relative to control so
what you see are a lot of asterisks so a
lot of these interactions are pathogenic
those species do significantly decrease
survival but the range of that is really
broad so
some of these are just acting as a
pathogen so this is pythium in gestatum
you can see that the survival for
equilibrium is pretty much zero when
inoculated whereas for fragments it's
very high
so those are having a that's picking
species having a really different effect
on those two um whereas other technium
dissimile is very similar
but some although it's a pathogen for
both it's a far more virulent pathogen
for one relative rather than the other
so if you look at pythagorean
accumulative here you can see that
epilipium glandular someone inoculated
has pretty much zero sequence survival
whereas phragmites despite the fact that
it's significantly reduced relatively
controlled
it's not that burial in the package
so if we
divide this up by where these plant
species are coming from and look at the
effect of all of the pivotal species
green being native and yellow being
invasive you can see that
the proportion seedling survival it
isn't clearly
higher for the invasive plant species so
if you think back to immune release it
would say that these invasive plants are
going to be less susceptible to
pathogens and we're not seeing that
across the board one of the most
susceptible plant species lithium
salicaria is invasive
but at the same time the most uh
resistant of phalaris aminesia is
invasive too so they're not clear-cut
divisions between native and invasive
species
we can take this one step further
and look
at individual isolates of a given
species
that are
taken from either the pharmacies invaded
or non-invaded soils to see if something
about fragments being there
makes this more virulent community and
so we did this for i think eight
different species
i'm just showing one here pythium and
transuridium but took isolates from both
the phragmites invaded
and non-invaded range and tested their
pathogenicity and virulence to a number
of plant species
which are different colors here and the
green are native
and the yellow is of the invasive
bronchitis so what you can see is that
there's not any big difference between
the isolates from the fragments invaded
and the vomit they respond really
similarly
for both for all the plant species we
looked at
so we're not seeing drag mites cultivate
an extremely virulent pathogen community
at least within species
so for the fungi here's another
heat map with the isolate source plant
the plant that were
the seeds that we're getting these fungi
from and then the plant species we
tested along here and you can again see
that epilobium glandulosum that
herbaceous native species is the most
susceptible with the darkest
and most red here the biggest decrease
in ceiling
um and the least is mule and very
inclinerata which is a native grass
these two invasives here of phragmites
and water and salicaria are kind of in
the middle
and isolates from some plant species
might be slightly more virulent than
others but it's really a mixed bag
so if we again divide this up in the
same way as the previous
group with online seats and look at
those individual fungal species
by these two plant species epiloguian
glandulosum and crackmardes
we see similar things that
a lot of these significantly reduce
survival relative to the control
but there's a big difference in the
virulence so the degree to which that
negative effect is happening
the most feral and pathogens are these
fusarium species no surprises there for
those of us in the planet college
department as well as some of these
alternate areas
but it's not necessarily a kind of
uniform across species so this
alternaria species it significantly
reduces ceiling survival for both
epilogue and glandularism and fragmities
but that's having a bigger effect on the
bowl
so we do the same thing and look at the
kind of sum of all of those fungal
species by plant species and by plant
species origin with the native species
in green and the invasive and yellow you
can see that again you're not seeing
clear cut
differences between the native and
invasive species some of these invasives
are very susceptible and others are not
and in this case the most susceptible is
still the thrombosalicaria
and the least is pharmacistalis so
right minds
so
getting back to our initial question are
these omysees and fungi pathogens of
marsh plants and so how virulent are
they
um we did find a lot of generalist
pathogens so they decreased seedling
survival of a range of plant species but
there were differences in their
virulence
and
when looking at whether native plant
species were more susceptible than
invasives this didn't seem to be true
for some
invasive plant species but not for all
so uh phthalates or indonesia was pretty
resistant to those um fungicides but
lithium salicaria another invasive was
highly susceptible
and similarly the pathogens from the
native species weren't more virulent
than those from the invasive
so to summarize
we found that phragmites changes the
soil in some way that decreases seedling
survival
and when we looked at that further we
found that
that was because of only seeds and fungi
in phragmites conditioned soil that were
increasing sealant survival
we found diverse and abundant omi seeds
and fungi in these marsh wetland soils
and the dominant
genera of these were pickium alternaria
foma and epicalcum
and we found different pathogens
associated with different plant species
so how do these fit into those
hypotheses i mentioned initially about
how invasive plant species might be
interacting with pathogens
so if we think back to enemy release
where part of the reason why an invasive
plant would be successful is because
it's leaving behind pathogens in its
native range and it's not acquiring them
in its invaded range
we would have expected to have seen that
invasive species were less susceptible
to pathogens in the invaded range than
native plants
and that the native plants were
accumulating more virulent pathogens
than the invasive plant species so did
we see this
we did for some invasive plant species
but not all so it's not a clear rule for
these marsh wetlands that invasive
plants are acting one way and maybe the
species are acting another way so it
does seem to be the case that alarmist
amnesia is less susceptible to these
pathogens
but for feminism and within salicaria it
doesn't seem to be
so this also doesn't get into the
question of we're just looking in its
invaded range so this doesn't tell us
what's happening in the native ranges of
these invasive species and what those
pathogen communities look like but at
least it gives us a little window on to
what's happening
and then thinking back to the other
hypothesis i mentioned that something
about the addition of this new plant
species this invasive plant is changing
the pathogen community in such a way
that it would decrease the success of
native plants
spill over or spill back
with that we would have expected that
the pathogen community changes after
invasives colonize
and that it increases the abundance or
virulence of pathogens after invasion
so did we see that
we did see that the pathogens seemed to
be different
if we looked at the omycin fellow
communities of different plant species
they were different but
we don't know if they're necessarily
more abundant or more virulent or what's
happening with that and what effects
those would have
on
the planet
so
i think that you know this research lays
the groundwork for more work into what's
actually happening in marsh wetlands we
now know
uh ritual my seats and flanders there
we have some idea of their host ranges
and their virulence
but i think one of the things that
definitely comes out is that marsh
wetlands are
a little different from the forest and
grassland systems where other people
have looked at
pathogen uh basic plant interactions and
i think that there might be a few
reasons for that so when people looked
at invasive plants and grassland and
marsh systems they tend to find a really
clear divide between the native plants
which behave one way and the invasives
that are different
and here we're finding that's not the
case that each plant species kind of
does the same thing and i think that
could be because marsh wetlands are just
different from those other two systems
marshes are even the native species tend
to be quick colonizers they tend to grow
in clonal stands
and they're just
different from those species and forest
grassland systems in addition i think
that we found a lot of generalist
pathogens
in these soils which might be uh
making it so that there's less
post-specific interactions and pathogen
interactions and more swellings but more
likely i think that if people
looked at a broader set of invasive
species in
other systems forest grassland systems
they'd probably find the same thing that
different invasive plants are
benefiting from different
interactions so some may be doing so
well because they're growing really fast
others may be interacting with soil
pathogen communities and that you can't
really make a blanket statement about
how invasives are active and how native
surrounding
so with that i want to thank everyone
who made this research possible um
eric thank you so much for being such a
fantastic advisor i really have grown up
for your mentorship and this is where
you have to sit sit with me because this
is an exit center i'm just not a normal
seminar so i get to thank everyone
marianne
right there i don't know what i'd do
without you in the lab you're one of the
few people who's as good in the lab as
in the field and marianne really was
essential for a lot of the it's
particularly the sequencing molecular
work behind this research
justin lance of fame undergraduate
assistant right there who is um
co-writing one of the papers i'll be
coming from my dissertation with me and
has really been a great help my
committee aaron blossie and allison
power
all of my many undergraduate assistants
everyone from the glossy lab vicky nuzzo
and andrea
and then my funding from the atkinson
center and the new york c grant and i
also want to give thanks to all of my
colleagues friends families
family for your support and
i know that's everything from helping me
in the field to listening to my practice
talk and hear my parents there my sister
and they can tell you that i have been
very into marshmallows ever since i was
a little kid so here is me doing
approximately what i'm still doing
so not much has changed there but i do
feel really grateful to have spent the
past five and a half years surrounded by
such a great group of
kind of
plant pathologists but also friends
so with that i'll take questions and
thank you all very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu